Hi, this is Ari Helchuk, the CEO of
Fruit
Signals, the platform for measuring,
controlling, and optimizing LLM based
agents, chat bots, and workflows both
for AI product companies and
enterprises. And today I'm trying to
answer the question whether agent
evaluation by MCP or model conduct
protocol could stabilize agents and
agent networks and
swarms. So most of us are already
thinking along the lines that if you
only had a stable agent swarm you could
in principle solve any kinds of
knowledge work problems. Uh and the only
limitation here is that those swarms
tend not to be stable when you try to
solve increasingly complex problems. And
the reasons relate to uh both for our
inability to observe them perfectly and
the dynamic environments uh difficulties
of testing them uh comprehensively
beforehand etc. And uh also it is often
not clear whether the agents are making
progress consistently towards the goal
in the cases where they just don't
achieve it on basically one shot. Uh so
uh how do we start uh solving this
problem in a more robust manner? The
general answer to question is going to
be evaluations or evals uh but not in a
way that you would think. So uh firstly
many people tend to oversimplify uh the
questions of question of evaluations and
uh if you just go out there and you you
basically just take some eval stack and
you add it then the outcome is is is
like this that alone will probably not
take you anywhere. just the same uh same
uh uh kind of outcome if you don't
actually systematically use evaluations
uh in a way that uh not only improves
those agents and workflows but also
those evaluation stacks themselves
continuously develop and uh and uh grow
more aligned with with your actual uh
business requirements. So the reason uh
this is difficult is fundamentally
because uh if you want to evaluate all
aspects of agent behaviors and internal
representations, you have a very complex
landscape as shown here. Uh on the links
below the video or attached to the
video, you can also find my previous
talk on this same topic where I I went
through this in more detail. But in
short you have both uh evaluations for
the left hand side which is uh in a way
the agent represents reality what how it
uh models the reality and discusses the
reality with the user and how it's
grounded to reality in terms of uh what
is true and on the other hand on the
right hand side you have behavioral
aspects such as whether the agent
actually infer the right goals whether
it's uh making progress towards those
goals whether it selects the right tools
on the path to get there etc etc. So in
principle you would want to evaluate all
these things but at least getting
started with some would probably take us
somewhere if we are just uh be able to
do that
consistently. Uh so first to get started
as an example uh we need to have some
kind of a a clear uh framework for
actually setting up the evaluators. So
for example in this case we are looking
at reservation agent for a hotel and for
this purpose we would have evaluators
such as uh the ones mentioned here like
policy adherence to that specific
hotel's uh reservation policy uh
accuracy of of the uh outputs of the
agent to the user and uh and then of
course the um the appropriate uh
behavior overall. Uh so you need to to
set up this evaluator somewhere. This
has have been set up uh in root signals
but wherever you do uh make sure that
you have both uh good visibility to how
you can create large stacks of
evaluators and how you can maintain them
and improve them systematically over
time when you when you have to run
dozens of them all the time.
Uh so what we want to achieve is uh is a
stabilization loop where uh the agent
attempts certain task it the output of
the task will get evaluated by the
evaluation engine and then feedback in
the form of numeric score and also a
explanation of what went wrong comes
back to the agent or the explanation of
what went well as well. uh so using that
information the agent can then improve
its own performance. So this needs to
come from the engine and in order to
attach these agents uh the new uh latest
greatest method is going to be the model
context protocol or the MCP. So let's
look at uh some practical examples next
and we will start with uh with something
very simple.
So for this uh first experiment we will
not even have code. We will just be
looking at at text. So if the agent or
whatever workflow you're running would
out output uh this sort of uh sentence
like routing MCP service awesome let you
access nicely and now you want to
measure and also improve uh
this specific text that might be coming
out of the agent. So for this purpose uh
you firstly need to find which evals you
want to run on it. So we can actually
ask uh the cursor UI uh through MCP to
firstly list the charges that I have
available. You can also list evaluators
directly. Charges would be collections
of evaluators in this uh specific
terminology. So I've already attached
the uh the the free root signals MCP
server that you can get from GitHub and
I just added it on on cursor and what
this MCP uh server lets you do is gives
you access to these evaluators and these
charges that I have created for myself
earlier and then some some universal
charges uh universal evaluators that can
be used used anywhere. So importantly
the first one here that I happen to be
interested in in this case was this
marketing message quality judge. So it
was just found by by what I wrote here.
So I can then very freely just uh or
loosely just uh ask cursor to measure
and improve this uh this marketing
statement on the left by just saying
that uh optimize the message by using
the marketing message
optimization
charge
and at this point cursor is going again
to through the MCP interface uh back to
the uh charge and evaluator stack. It
will find again that specific charge I
was interested in. It will score uh this
message on the left and then it will uh
try to figure out how to improve that
score and score it again if everything
goes nicely. So let's let's see if it's
uh able to actually do that. And this is
actually now real time. Okay, at least
it's finding various issues with it.
And then it continues uh the process of
trying to improve. Let's see if we can
we can get the scores. Okay, it's
already
suggesting an improved version of that
based on the scores. But let's see if we
also see the scores from from here.
Sometimes they are shown immediately,
sometimes uh they are shown later. So
apparently this time it didn't show the
original scores for us, but now it's uh
it's uh running the final evaluation to
get us with the final scores. If you
don't see the scores, you can actually
ask it to show them. Now it's showing
them. So okay, so persuasiveness,
quality writing, engagingness, uh
numbers shown here. You can see numbers
that that it started out with. You can
you can see uh final numbers. Now it's
only showing the the final final numbers
between zero and one. So this is
basically the same thing that will
happen inside your agent but now we just
called it manually to make it easy for
us to us to see. For the agent you can
either exactly explain which evaluators
and which charges to run or you can just
uh just let it pick uh pick them itself.
So next we'll look at an actual agent
example and uh now I want to be really
clear we are no longer talking to MCP
through cursor uh so I'm removing this
from from our field of view. Uh so I
have now an actual very simple uh cotal
reservation agent here uh running on
pyantic AI and this is uh this is just
just happens to be implemented or
actually uh view through cursor and uh
in in fact I'm going to run this uh this
uh separately on the console and uh what
happens in this uh uh reservation agent
is that the user is going to ask
something a little bit dangerous. So
this is a reservation agent for Shire
Hotel and
the SH hotel happens to be next to the
Akma hotel. So in no circumstances is
the Shire hotel reservation system
supposed to be uh recommending or
preferably saying anything about the
Akma hotel. Uh so the user is now asking
about the Sire specifically but actually
hinting that it would also be interested
on the on the hotel uh next to it. uh
bit maybe artificial example but just uh
showing this uh this very precisely what
is the problem. So let's see what
happens when you run this without the
MCP. So currently the MCP is off and
let's see what the agent returns. Okay,
it will uh politely say that there will
be rooms available a bit later, but it's
also saying that uh that the AKMA hotel
is also a great option. So, this is what
they don't want to see. So, let's go
back. We will turn on uh the MCP server
here and see if that makes a difference.
it just uh set this to true and it will
then add it will actually use this uh
this MCP server here for evaluation. So
let's go back to uh then running this
same command
again and while it's running it's uh
calling the MCP server here. So you will
see that uh there will be a lot of
activity happening where evaluators are
being listed and they will be uh there
will be calls back and forth through the
evaluator uh lists and running many of
them and some of them several times even
if we want to uh make maximum use of
this. All right. So as you can see now
the agent came back and now it's uh not
talking about the AMA hotel again and we
can see that it was invoking this hotel
sh booking policy evaluator even though
we didn't even ask it specifically to do
that. So it can uh in most circumstances
pick relevant ones from the list but you
can also uh enforce specific ones if if
if you want to be sure. Uh so this seems
to have worked and uh then let's go back
to the big
picture. So what we have now seen is uh
agent being attached to the evaluation
engine through the MCP and getting the
feedback and improving its own behavior
and you can see how this sort of
approach would scale to more complex
examples.
So then uh to uh
to summarize on how to approach this,
you should first start by making sure
that your evaluation library, evaluation
platform, whatever you're using is
sufficiently powerful to to support all
this both in terms of diversity of
evaluators that you can create and also
their life cycle maintenance and
optimization on both the uh letting you
both optimize the agent itself, but also
you need to be able to optimize uh the
uh the evaluators uh because uh you will
be running a lot of them and they will
cost you money. Also uh it's a good idea
to start with uh running TMCP manually
offline like we did with the marketing
message example. So you so that you
first understand roughly what is
happening and then you're able to uh get
better and better transparency to uh to
the uh ways in which those can work and
and not work. And finally then you will
be attaching them uh the letters through
the MCP uh to the agents and uh this
promises to make everything more
controllable, more transparent and also
like dynamically uh self uh improving
and
self-correcting. So this is all uh the
root signals MCP servers uh is available
for free. uh others will surely be be
appearing to allow all kinds of
evaluating evaluation platforms and
framework to be implemented uh as uh as
part of your uh agent stack. Uh so I
thank you for your interest and uh happy
hacking.